Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen sprechen über die internationalen Top-Ligen im Männerfußball. Wir begrüßen euch zur Ligatur hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 232. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr hört hier die Ligatur, ihr hört den Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ihr hört jetzt gerade noch Max Jakob Ost, den Edgenetzer, auf Twitter und ich begrüße hier bei mir eine schöne Runde. Zum einen Nils Kern von Real total und natürlich dem Tiki Taka Fußball Podcast zur Spanischen La Liga. Hallo Nils, schön, dass du hier bist. Alles prima. Ich freue mich jetzt auf die Sendung mit euch und begrüße ebenfalls hier Alexis Menuge, der einzige ohne eigenen Podcast hier in der Runde, wenn ich das gerade richtig sehe. Alexis, wo bleibt der League 1 Podcast von dir? Hallo.
Ja, das dauert nicht mehr lange, wenn ich sehe, was für tolle Geschichten der französische Podcast gerade produziert. Egal, ob bei den Männern oder bei den Frauen. Nur noch eine Frage von ja, Stunden vielleicht.
Ja, stark, sehr gut. Also ich werde ihn verlinken, wenn es ihn in ein paar Stunden schon gibt. Den musst du mir dann einfach schicken. Den Link. Und ebenfalls hier ist Marius Soyke vom Serie Amore Serie A Podcast. Hallo Marius, schön, dass du dich an die Regel hältst, hier einen eigenen Podcast mitzubringen in die Runde. Ja, und mir ist. Ich freue mich wirklich sehr auf die Sendung. Später werdet ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, auch noch Jogi Hebel hören vom Click and Rush Podcast zur Premier League. Das mussten wir separat aufzeichnen. Aus terminlichen Gründen. Es ist immer nicht so ganz einfach, hier einen Termin zu finden. Also ich würde es ungefähr auf eine Ebene stellen, mit der WhatsApp-Gruppe, der Grundschulklassen meiner Zwillinge. Wenn da ein Termin gefunden wird, das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn wir für die Ligatur einsuchen. Aber ihr seid wesentlich digital affiner und es geht schneller bei euch. Und es werden nicht noch mal Diskussionen aufgemacht, die man schon längst hatte. Wollen wir wirklich, wollen wir noch mal über den Inhalt reden, dürfen wirklich keine Muffins in die Brotzeitbox mitgegeben werden. Zählt das auch als Süßigkeit? Naja, ich will nicht ablenken, wir wollen keine Zeit verlieren. Bevor wir loslegen, sage ich aber noch, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt paywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und auch alle Gäste bekommen ein kleines Honorar immerhin von dem, was ihr uns überweist. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Würde uns freuen, wenn ihr da mal drauf schaut. Jetzt starten wir mit dem Rundblick. Ich würde sagen, wir beginnen mal bei dir, Marius. Wir beginnen mal in der Serie A. Du hast uns wie alle hier ein paar Themen mitgebracht, über die wir sprechen wollen. Unter anderem geht es um Inter in der Ergebnis-Krise. Beziehungsweise in der Krise. Was ist es denn jetzt nun? Also ist es nur eine Ergebnis-Krise oder wie schlimm schaut es da aus?
Also in der Ergebnis-Krise ist es auf jeden Fall. Da jetzt am Wochenende das Spitzenspiel gegen die Roma verloren, gegen den alten Trainer Mourinho, da schwingen dann natürlich auch ganz große Gefühle bei den Tifosi den Nerazzurri mit, obwohl Mourinho selbst gar nicht im Stadion war, sondern in einem Van davor, weil er gesperrt war. Und ja, man ist nicht wirklich zufrieden. Nach acht Spielen zwölf Punkte, Platz neun. Allerdings war das Spiel gegen die Roma jetzt so rein spielerisch gar nicht mal so mies. Also Einsatz hat gestimmt, das Offensivspiel, die Kombinationen haben eigentlich größtenteils gestimmt, was einfach nur gehabert hat, war der Abschluss. Und dann, leider, das zieht sich so ein bisschen durch die Saison, die Defensivarbeit. Man fängt sich in guten Phasen immer sehr unglücklich Gegentore. Und das ist etwas, das hat es in den letzten drei Jahren bei Inter eigentlich nicht gegeben. Und es scheint im Moment nicht so, als hätte Simone Inzaghi, der Trainer, gerade eine wirkliche Antwort darauf, was er dem entgegen zu ersetzen könnte. Also ich glaube, man hat jetzt 13 Gegentore in der Liga gefangen. Das sind ungefähr schon so die Hälfte oder ein bisschen weniger als die Hälfte von dem, was man letzte Saison, an der ganzen Saison kassiert hat. Und ja, das ist nicht das, was Inter möchte. Das ist nicht das, was der Kader eigentlich auch hergibt. Ich finde immer noch, dass der Kader der bestbestückte in der Serie A ist, so rein von der individuellen Qualität her. Nur läuft es halt irgendwie nicht mehr rund. Und deswegen entwickelt es sich halt so sukzessive von einer Ergebniskrise in eine richtige Krise rein. Weil man eben, wie gesagt, nicht das Gefühl hat, dass Insagi so richtig weiß, wie er das ändern soll.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel die Schüsse, die Inter zulässt pro Spiel anguckt, dann steht man da eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Da ist es nicht so herausragend gut wie in der letzten Saison, aber da ist man auf Rang 7 in der Serie A. Und dann, aber du hast es ja schon gerade angesprochen, bei den Gegentreffern wesentlich schlechter. Liegt das dann jetzt an individuellen Fehlern oder kommt da auch was Systemisches mit rein? Also wir kennen das ja von anderen Spitzenmannschaften, dass man eben so viele Spiele in der gegnerischen Hälfte hat, dass es dann logisch ist, dass wenn der Gegner mal umschalten kann, dass es dann so Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen hinten in der Defensive gibt. Und da verliert man halt dann auch mal welche. Ist das bei Inter auch der Fall? Oder liegt es eher so an Formschwächen oder anderen Dingen?
Ich würde sagen, dass es tatsächlich eher an individuellen Formschwächen liegt, denn das System ist im Vergleich gerade zu letztem Jahr natürlich, wo Insagi ja auch schon da war, nicht groß verändert. Und das ist ja auch nicht so anders als das, was Antonio Conte davorher etabliert hatte und womit er ja Meister geworden ist mit einer herausragenden Leistung in der Saison. Es ist nur einfach so, dass vor allem Stefan Defrey, der eigentlich jahrelang mit der beste Verteidigerin der Serie A war, mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr an diese Topform anknüpfen kann. Man hat dazu ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Milan Scrinia, um den es ja im Sommer sehr, sehr intensive Gerüchte mit PSG gegeben hat, Alexi kann da sicherlich auch was von der französischen Seite zu sagen, man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass er mit dem Kopf nicht so 100% bei der Sache ist. Es ist eigentlich so, also das ist, ich sage immer, und Mario Rica, wir bei Serie Amore sagen immer, das ist eigentlich so der Typ Verteidiger, den willst du als Stürmer auf keinen Fall spielen, weil der so heiß und so stark und so, ja, unangenehm zu bespielen ist, aber das ist diese Saison irgendwie alles ist nicht mehr so richtig da und ja, deswegen fällt es wahrscheinlich auch in Sagi so schwer, die Antworten darauf zu bekommen, weil er eigentlich, ja, weil es eben nicht so richtig an seinem System liegt, sondern dass es immer wieder individuelle Aussetzer gibt. Da spricht ja auch dann die Statistik, die du gerade vorgelesen hast, ein bisschen für, dass man so viele Chancen gar nicht zulässt, aber dann doch, wenn der Gegner dann mal wirklich vor's Tor kommt, dann machen sie die Dinger halt auch ein.
Also zu dem Kollegen Skriniar, ich hatte das Gefühl, gegen Bayern München am ersten Spieltag, das war ein paar Tage nachdem der Transfer, das Transferfenster, ja, zugemacht wurde, dass er mit dem Gedanken woanders war. Ich hatte das Gefühl, er ist gar nicht im Spiel drin und seitdem wissen wir auch, dass es eine ganz merkwürdige Saison ist, durch diese WM mittendrin und dass der Transferfenster wieder bald eröffnet wird und ich glaube, wir werden natürlich auf der Trainerbank so viele Wechsel wie noch nie haben, auch aufgrund, dass es jetzt November, Dezember viele Spieler gibt, die auch Urlaub haben werden. Nicht nur diejenigen, die bei der WM dabei sind, sondern auch Urlaub haben werden, insbesondere bei unserem Thema jetzt Milan Skriniar und Paris Saint-Germain will ihn unbedingt haben, jetzt im Januar. Sein Vertrag läuft im Juni aus, wäre also eine Ablöse fällig, vielleicht hätte Inter ihn verkaufen sollen für 60 Millionen im Sommer. Hat man aber abgelehnt das Angebot von PSG, das ist Fakt, das ist nicht mal ein Gerücht. Er sollte als Abwehrchef nach Paris kommen, weil der Ramos nicht mehr der Jüngste ist und vielleicht dort nicht alle drei Tage spielen kann, auch wenn es momentan anders aussieht, Kim Pembe jetzt verletzt ist und Marquinhos eh schwichelt seit einem Jahr. Dann bist du dünn besetzt in der Innenverteidigung bei PSG, auch weil du jetzt mit einer Dreierkette spielst. Und wenn es jetzt in der K.o.-Runde losgeht, ich gehe davon aus, dass PSG ins Achtelfinale 1 hin wird, dann brauchst du mindestens einen Neuzugang auf dieser Position. Dann wäre der Slowenian natürlich herzlich willkommen. Und wie gesagt, mit der Tatsache verbunden, dass er die WM nicht bestreitet und dass am 28. Dezember die Ligue 1 vollgesetzt wird bereits.
Siehst du denn parallel, das ist jetzt ein kleiner Sprung, Alexis, aber wenn ich mir die Ligue 1-Tabelle angucke, dann sehe ich da auch ein Team, was erstaunlich viele Gegentore kassiert, dafür aber noch im Mittelfeld liegt, nämlich Lille. Die haben 18 Gegentreffer bei 17 Toren, also selbst erzierten Toren. Und dies scheint ähnlich wie Inter so eine Hopp- oder Topmannschaft aktuell zu sein. Also bei Inter ist ja vier Siege, vier Niederlagen aktuell die Bilanz. Bei Lille ist es vier Siege, einunerschieden vier Niederlagen. Gibt es da für dich also vergleichbare Dinge zu Inter?
Ja, beide Mannschaften waren letzte Saison in der Champions League dabei. Ich glaube, beide, Inter ist auch ins Achtelfinale eingezogen damals, wie Lille. Nur an Aczelci gescheitert im Achtelfinale. Und nachdem man Meister war vor zwei Jahren, aber auch wie Inter in Italien. Und jetzt hat man einen neuen Trainer geholt, relativ bekannt mit Paulo von Seca, der Portugiese. Und auf dem Papier sollte eigentlich Lille immer unter den Top 5 sein, wo es den kanadischen Nationalspieler Jonathan David, der bei der WM dabei sein wird. Man hat die Mannschaft klug verstärkt. Natürlich hat man wichtige Bestandteile der Mannschaft im Sommer verkaufen müssen. Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn man sich die anderen Teams anschaut, dann müsste Lille unter den Top 5 sein. Und mit dieser mangelnden Konstanz wird Lille sein ursprüngliches Ziel mit der Europapokal-Teilnahme nächste Saison wohl nicht erreichen. Vor allem, wenn du in Lorient verlierst, eine Mannschaft, die eigentlich nichts da oben zu suchen hat, sondern eher unten, und vor allem knappe 45 Minuten zu 10 spielt gegen 11 Lille-Oise und am Ende Donner, das 2-1-Eziel kurz vor Schluss Lorient, dann kann man sich schon fragen, was da bei Lille los ist. Vielleicht gibt es auch nicht nur ein Qualitätsproblem, weil das sehe ich nicht unbedingt, sondern eher ein mentales Problem bei den Nordfranzosen, bei den Doggen, wie die so schon genannt werden. Deswegen gibt es momentan viele Parallelen zwischen Lille und Inter. Nur der große Unterschied ist, dass Lille noch nie so oft wie Inter-Mailand im Viertelfinale der Champions League war. Nämlich noch nie.
Ich habe das Gefühl, du hast dir jetzt schon eine Brücke gebaut zu einem Thema, das du eben mitgebracht hast. Weil man kann natürlich fragen, was ist bei Lille los, wenn die gegen Lorient verlieren. Man kann aber auch die Frage stellen, und da wirst du mir jetzt Antworten geben oder uns Antworten geben. Was ist denn eigentlich bei Lorient los? Tabellenplatz 3, 22 Punkte. Man hat erst einmal verloren in neun Spielen. Du hast gesagt, sie gehören da eigentlich oben nicht hin.
Warum? Also es wäre schon ein Ding, wenn Lorient in die Champions League einsieht. Dann kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass wir schon eine Mannschaft fest haben im Top 4 in der Auslosung. Nächstes Jahr im August, aber Spaß beiseite, ist eine Mannschaft, die normalerweise unten dabei ist. Nicht zu vergessen, in dieser Saison, in Frankreich steigen die letzten vier ab. Es gibt keine Relegationsspiele, weil die Ligue 1 nächste Saison von 20 auf 18 Mannschaften reduziert wird. Die ersten zwei der zweiten Liga steigen direkt auf. Bei den Beobachtern war klar, dass die Bretonen zu den heißesten Abschließkandidaten gehören. Aber die haben jetzt einen Trainerwechsel vorangestrebt im Sommer. Dieser Le Brice, 46 Jahre alt, zum ersten Mal übernimmt er eine Ligue 1-Mannschaft, also eine Mannschaft in einer ersten Liga. Er war jetzt zehn Jahre bei der zweiten Mannschaft. Von seinem Weg her erinnert er schon ein bisschen um Christian Streis, vielleicht noch zu früh, um diese Entwicklung vorauszusehen. Aber er macht es einfach fantastisch.
Und war er auch als Trainer bei der zweiten Mannschaft zu lange? Also hat er schon mit 26 quasi schon angefangen, oder mit 36 war er bei der zweiten Mannschaft, und jetzt ist er 46, so ist es richtig.
Also immer Trainer gewesen bei der zweiten Mannschaft. Und als man seinen Vorgänger, Christoph Pellissier, im Sommer entlassen hat, weil Lorion fast abgestiegen war in der vergangenen Spielzeit, man hat es sich mit Hauch und Krach, hat man den Klassenerhalt auch noch geschafft, hat man nicht lange überlegt bei den Verantwortlichen. Es war klar, dass Registeur Brice der Nachfolger wird, weil viele sehen ihn schon, ein Hellseher, einer, der taktisch moderne Spiele lässt. Verschiedene Systeme mitten in einem Spiel auch, was für die Spieler schwierig werden könnte, aber man sieht, dass die Spieler seine taktischen Vorgaben sofort annehmen. Was man über ihn auch so sagt, über dieses Lobrist, dass er als ein Volksgeheimnis ist, dass wenn er Probleme seiner Mannschaft vor Problemen darstellt, dann gibt er nicht die Lösung selber, sondern versucht, dass seine Spieler die Lösung selber finden. Auch wenn es da in der Kabine vielleicht stundenlang dauern sollte, aber er will, dass die Spieler sich Gedanken machen, dass sie da tief in ihre Gedanken gehen und selber die Lösung suchen, bis irgendeiner es gefunden hat, weil ansonsten wieder sie nie loslassen. Das sorgt schon für viel Anerkennung in der Mannschaft, im Verein. Eine Mannschaft, die mit viel Leidenschaft, mit viel Elan spielt. Und jetzt gegen Lille zu zehn gespielt, ohne zu glänzen. Aber trotzdem noch das 2-1-Kurz vor Schluss als Ziel, weil auch einfach da Selbstvertrauen da ist. Natürlich ist man gespannt, wie lange diese Euphorie anhält. Vielleicht sogar bis zur WM-Pause, schauen wir mal. Aber Lorient hat schon größere Namen bezogen in dieser Saison, wie Ulan Piclion zuletzt auch wieder mit drei Treffern erzielt. Also ein Krampf von den Klassenerhalten sieht schon mal sehr, sehr gut aus bei den Lorientais. Und das ist definitiv die Sensation. Man hatte ja von Lens gesprochen bei der letzten Sendung. Aber Lorient ist natürlich die noch größere Sensation, allein vom Namen her, vom Budget. Das Budget ist vielleicht unter den letzten fünf in der Liga 1 gerade. Und man ist bei 40 Millionen Euro, da 35. Also eine größere Sensation als Lens, was man schon eher erwartet, dass diese Mannschaft unter den ersten sechs, sieben ist, und die schon mal Meister war. Lorient ist noch nie Meister geworden, hat auch noch nie Europapokal gespielt in seiner Geschichte.
Hat auch den viertjüngsten oder drittjüngsten Kader, die Liga 1. Und das finde ich ja fantastisch. Der sokratische Ansatz jetzt auch bei Trainern, wir machen so lange Mannschaftssitzung, bis jemand von euch rausgefunden hat, warum wir immer in Konter laufen. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, da würden manche Teams dran verzweifeln. Da würde man dann nach drei Tagen bivak dann sagen, okay, wir brechen es ab. Verteidigt einfach bitte anders. Aber finde ich herausragend. Das klingt wirklich ganz, ganz fantastisch. Ich habe das Gefühl, von dem werden wir nochmal was hören. Von LeBri. Das klingt super.
Und wenn man sich jetzt den Spielplan anschaut, dann sieht es richtig gut aus, weil die Gegner fast alle bis zur WM gegen den Abstieg spielen. Paris Saint-Germain steht erst nach der WM auf dem Programm. Und dann hast du einen PSG als Gegner, der wahrscheinlich ohne Neymar, Mbappé, Messi, weil die alle entweder WM ausverdauen müssen oder Weltmeister geworden sind und immer noch in Rio, Buenos Aires oder Monaco rumtanzen. Und die werden eh nicht vor Februar wieder bereit sein. Und dann ist es natürlich die Chance für Lorient auch, für eine größere Sensation zu sorgen. Aber im Kopf wird auch Libris dafür sorgen, dass seine Spieler die kommenden Gegner nicht unterschätzen oder nicht auf die leichte Schulter nehmen. Und wenn man sieht, wie es bei den anderen Clubs läuft, wie Lyl eben gerade erwähnt, dann ist Lyon zuzutrauen, sich zumindest in Top 5 zu etablieren, zumindest bis zur Rückrunde.
Also Libris, den Namen merken wir uns in jedem Fall. Und ich mir hoffentlich auch die korrekte Aussprache. Nils, gibt es denn in La Liga einen vergleichbaren Trainer? Gibt es den? Komm, sagen wir es einfach, wie es schön formuliert ist. Wer ist der spanische Christian Streich?
Der spanische Christian Streich ist so sympathisch und so kultig, gibt es vielleicht keinen Grad. Aber um da vielleicht bei einem meiner Themen direkt zu landen, ich glaube Ernesto Valverde hat schon auch mittlerweile nicht nur einen gewissen Kultstatus nach jetzt über 2-jähriger Pause. Er ist zurück beim Athletik-Club und sorgt da aktuell für das Intime der Stunde in der Liga. Bilbao steht auf Platz 3. Das ist logisch, immer noch Early Days. Ein Athletico klettert schon noch hoch. Aber Bilbao sorgt aktuell richtig für Furore. Die haben jetzt schon in 3 Partien jeweils 4 Tore erzielt. Das gab es unter Marcelino, dem vorherigen Trainer, insgesamt, glaube ich, nur 3-mal. Und irgendwie ist da einfach Offensiv-Power aktuell angesagt. Sie sind da verdient oben mit dabei. Sie sind ja ohnehin auch ein besonderer Club. Viele Zuhörer oder alle Zuhörerinnen vom Rasenfunk wissen das bestimmt, dass der Athletik-Club ja nur mit Spielern aus dem Baskenland arbeitet. Also da gibt es quasi nie Zugänge. Man muss immer irgendwie auf den eigenen Nachwuchs schauen. Und trotzdem ist man noch nie aus der Liga abgestiegen. Also das ist schon mal eine besondere Geschichte. Und jetzt mittlerweile auch unter Walwerde geht es auch wieder nach oben. Man hat die letzten Jahre so ein bisschen im Mittelfeld rumgedümpelt. Aber unter Walwerde, früher, der ist jetzt schon zum 3. Mal Trainer in Bilbao, hat man schon regelmäßig nach Europa geschafft. Und da sieht es auch aktuell sehr gut danach aus, auch wenn erst sieben Spieltage gespielt sind.
Aber was hat sich denn dann verändert? Also gerade weil er jetzt schon so häufig war. Ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte mich nicht getraut zu sagen, wie oft er jetzt schon gefühlt war. Er war für mich quasi immer da. Ich musste jetzt erstmal kurz nachschauen, wer war denn eigentlich so zwischenzeitlich da. Irgendwas muss sich ja verändert haben. Oder ist das jetzt so eine Bestandsaufnahme? Ich meine, wir haben erst den siebten Spieltag. Kann natürlich auch am Spielplan gelegen haben, dieser Überflug.
Ja, also unter Marcelino ist man ganz gut gestartet. Der ist 2020, glaube ich, gekommen. Da hat man dann direkt mal die Supercopa gewonnen. Aber irgendwie ist die Mannschaft nie so richtig vom Fleck gekommen. Es war dann oft nur ein Schnitt von 1,3 Toren pro Partie irgendwie. Es hat auch einen Mittelstürmer gefehlt da, nachdem Aritz Adouris seine Karriere beendet hat. Und das war auch eigentlich in diesem Sommer das große Thema. Immer noch kein echter Mittelstürmer da, weil man keinen verpflichten kann. Aber Valverde hat ein paar Dinge umgestellt. Jetzt ist eben Iñaki Williams, die alleinige Spitze, nicht mehr mit Raúl Garcia. Ika Munyain ist jetzt im Zentrum gesetzt. Dort scheint er sich ein bisschen wohler zu fühlen, vielleicht noch als vorher links außen. Auch wenn er da sehr gut gespielt hat. Alex Bernanke ist der Topscorer der Mannschaft. Der dadurch jetzt ist seine Position links frei geworden. Und darauf konnte Marcelino noch nicht setzen, dass Nico Williams, der andere Bruder von Iñaki Williams, da jetzt so einen Sprung noch mal gemacht hat in seiner Entwicklung. Also die beiden treffen aktuell regelmäßig als Brüderpaar in der Liga, schreiben da eine besondere Geschichte. Beide sind jetzt auch für ihre Nationalmannschaften debütiert. Innerhalb von 24 Stunden in Iñaki für Ghana, Nico für Spanien. Und sind da aktuell voll im Höhenflug und darauf Setzwallwerde. Und lässt einfach auch angreifen, guten Fußballspielen, wo nicht mehr nur das Heiß verwalten, sondern Athletik gibt die drittmeisten Schüsse ab nach Real und Barca. Und ist trotzdem noch eine faire Mannschaft und hat da einfach aktuell das berühmte Momentum. Und läuft einfach sehr viel richtig aktuell.
Das hört sich allerdings so an. 16 zu 4 ist auch eine fantastische Bilanz. Sprich aber auch dafür, dass neben all der Offensive auch die Defensive, zumindest nur den Toren nach, jetzt auch sehr erfolgreich steht. Selbe Frage im Grunde, ist das jetzt Zufall? Gibt es da ganz viele Großchancen, die ich logischerweise nicht rauslesen kann aus diesen vier Gegentreffern, die die Gegner nicht genutzt haben? Oder macht da Athletik etwas anders als andere Teams?
Die Defensive war schon immer so das Prunkstück der Basken. Man hat da den Nationaltorhüter mit Unais Simon. Inigo Martinez ist ein Innenverteidiger. Der könnte es schon auch noch zur WM schaffen mit Spanien. Da ist man eigentlich auch immer ganz gut aufgestellt. Aktuell da eben noch besser, weil Valverde vielleicht irgendwie die richtigen Schrauben dreht. Der ist ja eh auch zurückgekehrt als Versprechen des neuen Präsidenten. Da gab es Präsidentschaftswahlen und wurde dann eben gleich gesagt, wenn ich gewählt werde, dann hole ich Valverde zurück. Dadurch die meisten Stimmen bekommen und da einfach jetzt eine neue Aufbruchsstimmung. Wenn man die Heimspiele im San Marmes anschaut, dort steht, dort sitzt keiner, dort, das sind wirklich teilweise Festspiele. Und es ist einfach interessant, das anzuschauen. Und wie gesagt, mittendrin diese Williams-Brüder, die ja auch eine besondere Geschichte haben, weil die Mutter ist damals schwanger mit Iñaki oder die Eltern geflüchtet aus Ghana, mit barfuß durch die Sahara dann im Wasteland gelandet. Und jetzt sind die beiden da Profi-Spieler beim Athletik-Club. Und so passiert da aktuell. Iñaki ist sowieso auch eine kuriose Geschichte. Der hat jetzt in den letzten sechs Jahren kein einziges Ligaspiel verpasst. Das sind mittlerweile 240 Spieltage am Stück, die der absolviert hat. Logisch, Athletik hat nicht so die Doppelbelastung. War zuletzt nicht mehr oft im Europapokal oder eher auch nicht oft bei der Nationalmannschaft. Aber es gibt aktuell viel Positives eigentlich aus Bilbao zu berichten.
Also aktuell Rang 3 in jedem Fall. Ich habe jetzt panisch gesucht, welches sonstige positive Thema haben wir, um da noch anzuknüpfen. Es gibt jetzt aber nur noch negative Themen, bis auf Marius. Der will nämlich noch über Udinese Kai Cho sprechen. Und das wollen wir natürlich sehr gerne tun. Die liegen nämlich auch aktuell auf dem 3. Rang. Logischerweise nicht in La Liga, sondern in Serie A. Wer hätte es gedacht? Aber Marius, wie haben die es denn dahingeschafft?
Das ist auf jeden Fall, wenn Lorient die große Sensation in der Liga ist und jetzt Bilbao vielleicht auch so ein bisschen in der Liga, wobei die auch schon eigentlich immer so unter die großen Clubs zählen, ist es also Udinese auf jeden Fall in der Serie A. Mal gucken, wer da um sie herum steht. Napoli, Atalanta, Lazio, Milan, Roma, Juventus. Das sind so die Tabellennachbarn. Und ich glaube, das letzte Mal als Udinese so weit oben stand, da hat Antonio Di Natale noch da gespielt, da hat Vincenzo Iacquinta noch da gespielt, da haben sie gegen Werder Bremen in der Champions League gespielt. Und der Präsident Gianpaolo Pozzo, dem ja auch, wissen Sie, dessen Sohn ja auch Rottford gehört, da gibt es ja immer so ein bisschen Hin- und Hergeschiebe von Spielern. Deswegen ist Udinese in den letzten zwei Jahren an Spieler wie Roberto Pereira und Gerardo Lofeo zum Beispiel gekommen. Der ist auch optimistisch, was das Ziel anbelangt. Also der möchte auf jeden Fall gerne nächstes Jahr Europäisch spielen. Und bisher geben sie auf jeden Fall, gut, das sind acht Spieltage. Da soll man jetzt den Tag noch nicht vor dem Abend loben. Aber bisher geben sie keinen Anlass, warum man sagen sollte, ey, warum sollten die nicht irgendwie jetzt auch am Saisonende die große Überraschung sein? Also das ist eine Mannschaft, die komplett über das Kollektiv kommt. Die haben im Sommer den Trainer gewechselt. Da ist der der alte Trainer Joffi ist zu Hellas gewechselt. Die sind jetzt gerade 18. Hatten aber auch einen sehr großen Ausverkauf an Stammspielern. Und bei Udinese ist Sotil der neue Trainer. Der hat Andreas Sotil, genau, ich musste gerade nochmal gucken. Ricardo Sotil, das ist sein Sohn, der ist Profi bei der Fiorentina. Andreas Sotil, der ist Anfang der 2000er, als sie auch mal oben mit dabei waren, Spieler bei Udinese gewesen. Hat also so ein bisschen Stallgeruch. Und er kam von Ascoli aus der zweiten Liga und hat das E schon eigentlich relativ gut funktionierende 3-5-2-3-4-2-1-System, immer mal je nachdem, wer in der Offensive da am Start ist, finde ich noch mal wesentlich verbessert. Also man hat zwei unglaublich starke Außenspieler mit Destiny Udoji, der nächstes Jahr zu Tottenham zu Konte wechseln wird, und eben dem Kapitän Roberto Pereira auf der rechten Seite. Udoji ist so einer, der rennt permanent die Grundlinie rauf und runter und kommt mit unglaublich viel Dynamik, ist sehr torgefährlich und Pereira ist so ein bisschen abwuller als rechter Schienenspieler, agiert so ein bisschen der Spielmacher. Über den geht eigentlich jeder kreative Angriff, aber insgesamt verschiebt die Mannschaft als komplette Mannschaft unglaublich gut. Sie machen die Räume eng in der Defensive, sie nutzen aber, wenn sie was angeboten bekommen, das Offensiv relativ eiskalt aus, sind unglaublich kampfstark. Das sieht man, finde ich, auch daran, dass in den letzten Spielen häufig Tore in der Nachspielzeit, in der zweiten Halbzeit gefallen sind. Jetzt auch das Spiel gestern Abend, am Montagabend gegen Hellers, bei Hellers haben sie durch Jakabiol in der 93. Minute gewonnen. Da übrigens der Assist von Laza Samadzic, der Ex-Hertha-Talent und RB Leipzig, der auch mittlerweile eine ziemlich gute Rolle spielt. Jetzt nicht immer in der Startelf gesetzt, ist aber schon sehr regelmäßig an seine Einsatzminuten kommt und da auch scoort. Dazu auch andere, erst der Bundesliga bekannte Gesichter gestern in der Startelf. Walaqi, der Ex-HSV-Spieler, Tolga Arslan auch eingewechselt worden gestern Abend. Hezibue, Ex-Kölner ist auch in dem Team. Denkt man eigentlich so, dass das alles gar nicht so die Spieler, die für Platz 3 in der Serie A sprechen, aber dieses Team funktioniert einfach wirklich unglaublich gut. Das macht auch Spaß, denen zuzusehen. Obwohl Udinese immer so ein bisschen eine richtige graue Maus ist, aber diese Saison sind sie irgendwie geil.
Und vor allem das Interessante ist ja, dass Udinese, und das ist jetzt vielleicht ein kleiner Unterschied zu Athletik und Lorient, fällt mir erst jetzt auf, dass wir über drei Drittplatzierte aktuell in ihren Tabellen, in ihren Ligen sprechen. Ich glaube, der Unterschied ist schon, dass man gegen ein paar größere Mannschaften schon gespielt hat. Also die einzige Niederlage, die war gegen den AC am ersten Spieltag mit 2 zu 4. Aber man hat zum Beispiel gewonnen gegen die Fiorentina. Man hat gewonnen mit 4 zu 0 sogar gegen die Roma. Man hat gewonnen mit 3 zu 1 gegen Inter, über die wir ja auch schon gesprochen haben. Also da waren jetzt schon ein paar größere Vereine mit dabei, wo man eben sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt nicht nur Spielplan, dass Udinese so weit oben liegt, sondern da steckt auch was dahinter.
Auf jeden Fall. Also gerade bei dem Roma-Spiel hat man es eigentlich gesehen. Die waren zu dem Zeitpunkt auch richtige, sind hochgeflogen, wenn man das so von Englisch auf Deutsch übersetzen kann. Und sind da so auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückgeholt worden. Und der Trainer-Neuling Sutil, der vorher noch nicht in der Serie A aktiver, hat da dem großen Jose Mourinho schon fast eine kleine Lehrstunde verpasst, was kollektive Arbeit als Mannschaft anbelangt. Und von daher hast du vollkommen recht. Da sind große Gegner dabei gewesen. Gut, Inter war es auch schon in dieser angesprochenen Ergebniskrise. Aber man nutzt eben auch einfach die Chancen, die man bekommt. Und deswegen sind sie völlig verdient da, wo sie jetzt gerade stehen.
Nämlich Aufrang 3. Und damit beenden wir den positiven Part. Ab jetzt wird es nur noch ganz schrecklich. Wir haben noch ein kleines, kleine positive Themen. Aber jetzt müssen wir auch über Krisenteams ein bisschen sprechen. Alexi, lass mal in die Ligue 1 gehen. Da beschäftigen wir uns auch. Wir haben jetzt gerade viele Namen genannt, die wir alle kennen aus der Bundesliga-Zeit. Jetzt wird mit Peter Boss ein weiterer dazu kommen, über den wir ja schon gesprochen haben. Bei Olympique Lyon läuft es nicht ganz so gut. Was ist da los?
Ja, nicht seit gestern. Eigentlich war damals ja Lyon im Halbfinale der Champions League. Vor zwei Jahren bei dem Final Eight in Lissabon an Bayern München gescheitert. Aber trotzdem damals lief es nicht mehr so rund bei Olympique Lyon. Siebenmal Meister in Folge. Das hat nicht mal der Stadt Paris Saint-Germain geschafft, sondern Lyon ohne Scheich. Seit drei, vier Jahren ist Lyon nicht mehr in der Champions League. Bis auf diese 19, 20-Kampagne. Lyon war bekannt, vor allem junge Spieler vorzuheben. Dass die dann bekannt werden, wie Karim Benzema, wie Atem Benahfar, wie Gordon Tolisso zuletzt. Das schaffen sie auch nicht mehr. Da ist auch keine klare Kontinuität mehr auf der Bank. Man kann natürlich einen Teil der fällenden Entwicklung der Radiant Peter Boss ziehen, der auch keinen großen Erfolg in Deutschland feiern konnte. Weder bei Borussia Dortmund, noch bei 04 Leverkusen. Aber er ist jetzt eineinhalb Jahre in Lyon. Man sieht überhaupt keinen sportlichen Fortschritt. Trotzdem bleiben die Verantwortlichen hinter ihm. Sein Glück ist einfach, dass gerade ein Eigentümerwechsel bei Olympique Lyon stattfindet. Du kannst den Trainer ausschmeißen. Auch wenn du jetzt gerade viermal in Folge verloren hast, eine Premiere seit über 30 Jahren bei Olympique Lyon, bei 50 Jahren sogar, 1971. Erst muss der Eigentümerwechsel unter Dar und Fach gebracht werden. Und dann kann natürlich ein neuer Trainer kommen, womöglich auch erst zur WM-Pause. Aber man sollte es schon vorher machen. Das Ziel von Lyon, das in dieser Saison nicht im Europapokal dabei ist, wenn er so weitermacht, auch in der kommenden nicht, muss wieder für positive Schlagzeilen sorgen. Weil es ist schon eine Mannschaft, die den zweitgrößten Budget hat in der französischen Liga. Der auf dem Papier noch sehr gute Spieler hat, mit Tolisso, Lacazette, Jerome Boateng, der jetzt auch so gut wie weg war, eigentlich von Bosz gewollt vor einem Jahr. Komplett aus dem Kader gestrichen seit einem halben Jahr. Jetzt war er verletzt und sollte verkauft werden, ist dort noch geblieben. Jetzt stand er zum ersten Mal in dieser Saison im Kader, am Sonntag in Lens, zumindest solange Bosz da ist, nicht mehr spielen. Bosz wollte auch Czaddań Czakiri haben, hat er bekommen, und hat drei Monate wieder verkauft, weil er noch weniger Leistung gebracht hat als damals bei den Bayern. Du hast den selben Präsidenten auch seit mittlerweile 40 Jahren, Jean-Michel Olaß, der französische Uli Hoeneß, der auch nicht den richtigen Zeitpunkt findet, um aufzuhören. Das ist schon bitter für Lyon, weil man braucht in Frankreich eine zweite Lokomotive, wie man so schön sagt, hinter PSG. Und auf Lyon ist es momentan überhaupt nicht verlassen. Da ist man sehr gespannt, wie es da weitergeht, weil da gibt es auch viele Schulden, nachdem man den Nagels Neue Stadion gebaut hat. Einer der modernsten in Europa, der muss auch noch refinanziert werden. Und da machen sich die zahlreichen Anhänger zu Recht viele Sorgen.
Kennst du den aktuellen Stand bei der Übernahme? Weil ich habe gelesen, dass da ein Problem sein soll, dass die Zinsen für aufzunehmende Kredite so gestiegen sind. Das ist ja jetzt was, das würde sich nicht in den nächsten Wochen schon wieder verändern.
Natürlich gibt es die Gefahr, dass der Deal platzt. Das war natürlich ein herber Rückschlag für Roland Piclion, sein Präsidenten. Man bleibt trotzdem zuversichtlich, dass der Deal über die Bühne geht in den nächsten Tagen. Deswegen, wegen den Zinsen, ist der Deal jetzt ein bisschen verschoben worden. Als ursprünglich gedacht. Aber man versucht mit aller Macht, dass der Deal stattfindet. Natürlich ist es blöd auch für OL und für den jetzigen Präsidenten, Olaß, dass Lyon einen Spieler dem anderen in der Ligue 1 verliert. Dass man sich nicht in der Europa League oder sogar Champions League zeigen kann. Aber aus Lyons Sicht hofft man trotzdem. Und man geht davon aus, dass der Deal bis spätestens Ende Oktober unter Darumfahrt gebracht wird.
Ja, genau. Lyon ist mir auch immer so als Verein der sehr, sehr guten Jugendarbeit in Erinnerung geblieben. Kommt denn da jetzt nicht jemand nach, der irgendwie auch in der Lage wäre, die Wende herbeizuführen? Also ich glaube, Ryan Cherki ist zum Beispiel immer sehr gelobt worden in den vergangenen Jahren. Hat sich das so ein bisschen verändert in Lyon?
Das große Problem ist halt, wie in der französischen Gesellschaft, ist die Mentalität. Ryan Cherki ist wahnsinnig begabt, aber nichts im Hirn. Das heißt, dass er jetzt seine Chance von Anfang an in Lens bekommen hat. Er spielt nur für sich, will nur für die Show agieren, kommt in Steilung an mit Sonnenbrille bis zur Kabine. Und so ist das Verhalten. Ich kann es nicht erwarten, dass er sein Potenzial ausschöpft. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum der Verein mit ihm vor kurzem verlängert hat. Ich hätte ihn schon längst rausgeschmissen. Er hat sich mit Jérôme Boateng an der Kabine angelegt vor einem Jahr. Ich kann Jérôme irgendwie verstehen. Er war zehn Jahre an der Säbener Straße, Top-Profi-Einstellung von allen. Jetzt kommt er nach Lyon, wo er solche Amateur-Verhalten sieht, mit dem er nicht klarkommt, völlig nachzuvollziehen. Und Cherki war einer der Hauptakteure, die auch für die miese Stimmung sorgen. Es gibt noch andere jungen Spieler, die sich nicht weiterentwickeln, wie Maxence Gagret, auf der Position von Tholissot, auch sehr begabt, auch technisch sehr stark, aber auch keine Konstanz, weil auch der Verein keine Konstanz mehr zeigt. Es ist schon sehr schade, man vermisst einen Signal-Govu, der damals allein die Bayern in der Gruppenphase 2-1 mit einem 3-0 weggefeckt hatte. Es gibt sehr viele Beispiele, aber Cherki ist da ein Rotustuch, zumindest bei mir.
Aber wirklich. Und auch interessant, immer diese Investoren-Geschichten zu hören. Das ist etwas, was wir immer in der Liga-Tour haben und in der Bundesliga nicht. Und jetzt sehen wir es eben hier bei Lyon. Scheitert es gerade an den Zinsen. In der Premier League habe ich jetzt mit Jogi dann gar nicht darüber gesprochen, was ihr noch später hören werdet. Aber da gibt es gerade über Everton Diskussionen, ob da ein US-Investor übernimmt. Das wäre dann der 10. Premier League-Club, der an US-Investoren geht. Da stellt man sich die Frage, warum. Unter anderem deshalb, weil das britische Pfund gegenüber dem US-Dollar abgestürzt ist. Das könnte vielleicht auch mit dem Brexit zu tun haben. Und deswegen, solche Übernahmen gerade auch relativ günstig sind. Zumindest eben in dieser Konstellation ein US-Unternehmen kann mit Dollars sich einen britischen Verein kaufen. Das sind ganz andere Themen, die wir hier haben. Mir persönlich fehlt es nicht, dass ich das in der Bundesliga nicht auch noch mitbesprechen muss. Aber gut, das ist jetzt nur so ein kleiner Seitenschwenk. Nein, ich bin so ganz dankbar. Und ich bin auch ganz dankbar, dass ich zum Beispiel das zwar immer zur Kenntnis nehme, dass jemand wie Nils und wie Alex und wie Fabian, dass sie immer wieder sagen, ja, ja, da kam ein neuer Präsident und der hat das und das versprochen. Und deswegen wurde das und das gemacht. Ich bin aber dankbar, dass ich mir die Namen nicht merken muss, weil das ist ja dann wieder so ein Kennzeichen von La Liga hatten wir jetzt ja auch schon bei Athletic Bilbao, dass da ein Präsident kommt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt auch irgendwie, ob wir da jetzt eine Brücke bauen können zum FC Sevilla, bin ich mir gerade nicht sicher, Nils. Ich weiß nur, das ist eins deiner Themen. Aber auf jeden Fall fällt es mir auf, in La Liga ist es häufig so, Präsidenten werden gewählt, indem sie etwas versprechen, etwas Konkretes. Ich hole euch Spieler XY, ich schole euch Trainer XY. Das geht ja bis hin zu, ich hole euch Figo von Barca zur Real rüber. Scheint irgendwie wichtig zu sein.
Das scheint immer so ein Faktor zu sein in Spanien. Und auch da ist Sevilla als Präsident, das ist José Caramona. Der hat zuletzt am Wochenende ein paar, ihm wurden ein paar Gesänge gewidmet im Sinne von erhöhe uns doch noch mal das Abo, Super Nuestro Canet. Wurden im Sommer die Dauerkartenkosten um 15% glaube ich erhöht. Ja, aber der Fußball hat ein bisschen gelitten. Sevilla ist aktuell viertletzter und da der Präsident steht in der Kritik, der Sportdirektor Monschi und Lupe Deguy. Ich hoffe, es hören noch ein paar BVB-Fans die Folge vor dem Champions League Spiel. Wenn der BVB nicht in Sevilla gewinnt, dann kann Tercic fast da bleiben, denn die Mannschaft glaubt nicht mehr dran. Lupe Deguy hält sich auch nur noch mit Parolen über Wasser. Es deutet alles darauf hin, dass am Donnerstag schon Jorge Sampaoli zurückkehrt und präsentiert wird. Also das ist heute wahrscheinlich Lupe Deguy's letztes Spiel in Sevilla.
Das ist ja krass. Lass mal bei Lupe Deguy bleiben, weil der war vor, weiß nicht, das ist doch gar nicht so lange her. Vor drei Jahren war der doch der heiße Scheiß auf dem Trainermarkt. Und man dachte, so wie der, so wird es in Zukunft laufen. Der neue Pep vielleicht sogar so ein bisschen.
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit, aber ja, ihr habt auf jeden Fall ein paar turbulente Jahre hinter sich. Allein schon bei der WM 2018, noch bei Spanien dann real zugesachten, dann kurz vor dem ersten Spiel noch gekündigt worden und entlassen worden. Bei real lief es dann auch nicht gut. Das war das erste Jahr nach Ronaldo und das konnte nicht gut verlaufen. Und dann hatte aber natürlich den FC Sevilla zurück in die Spur gebracht. Das war dann Sommer 2019. Da war Sevilla auch noch so am Finden. Die Zeit nach MRI mit den drei Europa League Titeln lange vorbei. Man hat viele Trainer verschlissen. Und dann kam Loupetegui und hat da wirklich viel Gutes bewegt. Das war speziell 1920 teilweise spektakulärer Fußball mit den Flügelzangen Reguillon und Jesus Navas. Aber da ist man eben immer mehr, obwohl man eine sehr wettbewerbsfähige Mannschaft hatte, mehr und mehr irgendwie zu so sehr vielen 1-0-Ergebnissen gekommen. Oder wenn überhaupt, allein in der letzten Saison, 16 der 38 Spieltage, hat Sevilla nur ein Tor überhaupt erzielt. Sehr viel Minimalismus, wenig Durchschlagskraft, das merkt man speziell in dieser Saison. Und da war eben dann im Sommer das fatale, in Anführungszeichen, weil das war eine bewusste Entscheidung von Monchi und Co., dass man so viele Spiele abgegeben hat. So viele wichtige Säulen mit eben Lucas Ocampos und dann natürlich der besten Abwehr der Liga. Jules Condé und Diego Carlos haben die wenigsten Gegentore vergangene Saison kassiert. Und da war schon mal klar, dass es jetzt keinen idealen Saisonstart vielleicht geben würde, aber nur fünf Punkte aus sieben Partien. Und dann eben auch jetzt aus den letzten Heimspielen, da war die Torbilanz 0 zu 9. Also City, Barca und Atletico auch keine einfachen Gegner. Aber die Mannschaft hat da wenig Power, noch wenig Feuer. Scheint da nicht mehr dran zu glauben. Neuzugänge wie Isco hat jetzt auch noch nicht so funktioniert. Und Lopetegis Zauber, auch wenn er sehr gut losgelegt hat, auch die Europa League gewonnen hat noch, ist da längst verglichen.
Ich hatte heute auch mit meinem Kollegen bei Transfermarkt Ivan Turmo gesprochen und ein kleines Stück zu Sevilla geschrieben. Der meinte, dass Lopetegi eigentlich, dass seine Zeit, was so die Meinung in der Stadt auch anbelangt, die Zeit eigentlich letzte Saison schon abgelaufen hätte gewesen sein müssen. Und dass es eigentlich an Monchi und auch an dem Präsidenten liegt, dass er überhaupt noch, klar, das sind die Führungskräfte im Verein, die müssen ja entscheiden, ob er gehen oder bleiben darf, aber dass die Fans eigentlich auch schon vorher seinen Abgang sich gewünscht hätten. Kannst du das auch so feststellen?
Ja, also speziell die vergangene Rückrunde wurden die Pfiffe immer lauter im Sanchez Pizjuán, wo man ja sonst auch eine sehr loyale Fangemeinde hat, die jetzt nicht die ganz großen Titelansprüche hat, aber trotzdem hatte man das Gefühl, man hat einen Kader und gegen diese schwächelnden Barca, schwächelndes Atletico, speziell vergangene Saison wäre vielleicht auch mal Platz 3 oder Platz 2 sogar drin gewesen. Man war im März auch noch dicht an Real dran auf Platz 2 und dann irgendwann die Mannschaft eingebrochen, da schon sehr viele Pfiffe und ja, gab es auch immer mehr Kritik, aber Lupe Degui hatte einen sehr hohen Kritik bei Monchi, beim Präsidenten, deswegen ist da jetzt auch in der Länderspielpause noch nichts passiert, obwohl man da ja Zeit hätte und jetzt sind ja trotzdem, wie viele Europapokal-Teilnehmer, was sind das, 12 Spiele in 40 Tagen bis zur WM? Da ist eigentlich jetzt schon kaum Zeit, noch einen neuen Trainer reinzubringen und deswegen hat Sampa Oli angeblich wohl noch um ein paar Tage Geduld gebeten, damit er nicht jetzt vor Dortmund gleich präsentiert wird, aber ja, die Laune in Sevilla ist nicht mehr gut, also zumindest nicht auf der rot-weißen Seite. Die Betty schreibt ja dagegen eine ganz andere Geschichte. Pokal geworden, dort herrscht Euphorie und beim FC Sevilla ist da aktuell, ja, man hatte auf Umbruch gehofft im Sommer, aber es ist ein Zusammenbruch geworden.
Und Jorge Sampa Oli heult in Sevilla an, er war schon dort, er will wieder alles umkrempeln, wir wieder eine Liste von Spielern haben, also viel Spaß in Sevilla, Marseille vermisst ihn nicht unbedingt, hat den Verein oder die Mannschaft im Stich gelassen, fünf Tage nachdem die Vorbereitung begann, weil er sich beschwert hat, dass er sicherlich davon ausgeht, dass er seine gewünschten Spieler nicht bekommt, die er haben möchte. Und ich bin mir auch sicher, dass er z.B. mit einem Jansu nicht klarkommen wird, weil Jansu vielleicht nicht der disziplinierteste ist, und wird sicherlich mindestens 15 Spieler haben wollen, jetzt schon im Winter. Das wird nicht unbedingt für Ruhe sorgen. Das würde mich wundern, auf jeden Fall.
War ja auch 16, 17 schon mal da, aber auch das nur ein halbes Jahr oder so. Also ist jetzt noch nicht mega-Erfolgsversprechend, dass es da für Sevilla jetzt deutlich wieder bergauf geht. Der Kader ist da natürlich für mehr als jetzt aktuell Platz 17. Aber ja, das ist eine schwierige Saison jetzt mit dieser vielen Belastungen. Und trotzdem hat man im Kader, die Spieler muss man einfach erst mal wieder erreichen, weil da führt aktuell nicht viel zusammen gegen Atletico, auch wenig Kampf. Man hat bei keinem Zweikampf gespürt, dass da irgendwie der Sevilla-Spieler mehr drin ist, mehr fokussiert ist als der Atletico-Spieler. Und das war jetzt die letzten Wochen eigentlich immer so.
Aber könnt ihr mir erklären, ich meine, ihr seid ja jetzt der Rat der Weisen des internationalen Männerfußballs, warum Sampaoli immer wieder neue Stationen bekommt, auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit? Also klar, es gibt diese Verbindung zum FC Sevilla, er war schon mal da. Aber wenn ich mir seine Bilanz angucke, egal ob als argentinischer Nationaltrainer, dann eben bei Sevilla selbst, er war auch bei Chile Nationaltrainer. Vielleicht war das die erfolgreichste Zeit, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Aber woher kommt das, dass der immer wieder auftaucht und jetzt ja auch bei Olympique unter diesen Umständen aufhört und dann sagt wenige Monate später ein anderer Verein, ja also bei uns läuft es jetzt gerade gar nicht, ach cool, du willst kommen und du willst jetzt ganz viele Spieler haben, ja natürlich machen wir das. Also ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Also ich glaube, dass Sampooli ein Stück weit auch vor allem tatsächlich immer noch durch diese Chile Zeit, wo sie mit ihm war das, zweimal die Copa Amerika gewonnen. Und der steht so ein bisschen für einen aufregenden Fußball und einen besonderen Ansatz. Ich hasse ja dieses Wort, aber ich glaube, es wird sich oft gedacht, um den und um seine Ideen kann man ein sogenanntes Projekt bauen. Eigentlich müsste man denken, wenn er sich bei jedem Verein so reagiert, und er ist ja auch meistens nicht länger als ein Jahr, wenn ich mir seine Station gerade hier nochmal angucke, vorher von Marseille bei Atletico Minero, FC Santos. Das ist jeweils ein Jahr gewesen, Sevilla genauso, Argentinien auch. Ja, müssten es die Manager oder Vereinspräsidenten besser wissen. Aber gut, oft tun sie das halt auch nicht. Vielleicht hat er auch eine ganz gute Verbindung.
Das scheint ja anscheinend ein netter Typ zu sein, mit dem man mal ein Abend verbringen kann. Sonst würde er ja nicht immer überall landen. Ich will ja auch nichts gegen ihn sagen, mir fällt es einfach nur auf.
Aber Max, wenn Markus Weinziel auch immer wieder einen neuen Verein findet, kann auch Hogi Sampoli...
Sehr ein exzellenter Punkt. Alexi, ich applaudiere dir. Das nimmt allen Fragen von mir tatsächlich komplett den Wind aus der Seele. Ja, du hast recht. Vielleicht überschätze ich da auch einfach, wie die Trainer-Auswahl kommt. Ich habe durchaus heute auch schon die ein oder andere Nachricht an mir bekannte Clubbärer verschickt. Da waren Fragezeichen enthalten und es kamen Ausrufezeichen zurück. Nicht unbedingt der optimistischen Sorte. Aber gut, geben wir Markus Weinz hier seine Chance. Wir sind mal gespannt, ob er sich komplett verändert hat. Jetzt haben wir noch kleinere Themen, über die wir sprechen wollen. Alexi, wenn du jetzt hier gerade eh schon mit dabei bist, dann sag uns doch mal, was ist denn in der Ligue 1 sonst noch zu beobachten? Wir sprechen jetzt, glaube ich, über einen Verein, der schon häufiger vorkam, nämlich Monaco. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, das, was du uns jetzt erzählen willst, das ist dann neu.
Ja, dass Alex Nübel nicht mehr kritisiert wird, nicht mehr so oft, dass er eine gewisse Stabilität zeigt seit der letzten Rückrunde. Und diese Stabilität hat er jetzt bestätigt in dieser neuen Saison bisher. Monaco momentan die Mannschaft der Stunde in Frankreich, 5 Siege in Folge. Natürlich bittet er immer mit Nübel und Monaco die Champions-League-Qualifikation nicht geschafft, immer in den Playoffs gescheitert, am PSV Eindhoven in dieser Saison. Wieder knapp in der Verlängerung. Jetzt tut man sich sogar schwer gegen Ferenc Varroche in der Europa League, aber in der Liga läuft es wieder. Man ist jetzt unter den Top 5 und man hat auf dem Papier auf jeden Fall auch da vielleicht den zweitstärksten Kader. Ich halte ihn stärker als von Olympique Marseille oder Olympique Lyon. Und Nübel hat sich definitiv da installiert. Man weiß ja, dass er bis Saisonende jetzt noch ausgelehnt ist von den Bayern. Es wird auch über eine Verlängerung gesprochen. Er will womöglich noch nicht zu Bayern zurückkehren, weil Manuel Neuer noch einiges vorhat. Aber nachdem er wirklich heftig kritisiert worden wurde, zum Teil zu Recht, weil er ein paar Patzer dabei hatte, aber ein bisschen übertrieben war die Kritik von Frankreich, weil man eigentlich gewohnt war, dass alle deutschen Kipper immer toll sind. Aber es ist ja eine neue Generation, die nicht mehr so toll ist wie in den 80er, 90er und Kranz-Zeiten und vielleicht Neuer noch. Aber er hat sich auf jeden Fall stabilisiert. Die Frage ist, ob er der würdige Nachfolger von Neuer wäre, aber ob er wirklich Weltklasse ist. Er hat schon einen besonderen Spielstil, also nicht unbedingt spektakulär oder elegant, sag ich mal, aber er hält alle die Bälle mit dem Kopf, mit der Schulter, mit allem drum und dran. Und auch sein Spiel mit dem Ball ist besser geworden oder am Fuß. Auch da macht er weniger Fehler. Und dadurch, dass er mittlerweile ein besseres Französisch spricht, läuft auch die Kommunikation besser mit seinen Vorderleuten. Und jetzt genießt er schon ein deutlich besseres Image in Frankreich. Und das ist schon mal eine gute Nachricht aus deutscher Sicht, weil bei den anderen Deutschen läuft es ja nicht so gut. Boateng haben wir schon erwähnt. Draxler und Kera sind ja mehr oder weniger rausgeschmissen worden von PSG.
Also Alexander Nübel von den Torhütern, die alle neun Spiele gemacht haben oder mindestens fünf oder mehr ist er der mit den meisten Paraden pro Spiel, die er erhalten kann. Und auch in der Passquote steht er ganz gut da. Also da ist er auf Rang 4, wenn ich das hier gerade richtig sehe. Wobei, ne, da sind ja auch Torhüter vor ihm, die nur zwei, eins und zwei Spiele gemacht haben. Also ja, scheiden tatsächlich eine Weiterentwicklung gemacht zu haben. Das würden natürlich manche freuen, jetzt die hier zu hören, glaube ich. Interessante Entwicklung. Dann haben wir auch noch ein kleineres Thema aus der Serie A. Worüber wirst du uns noch klären, Marius?
Da sind wir dann wieder im negativen Bereich. Zum Glück, zum Glück nicht ganz am Ende. Da kommt er dann noch aus Spanien wahrscheinlich, was vielleicht ein bisschen positiver ist, hoffentlich. Der 20. Platz, Sampdoria Genoa, ganz, ganz großer Traditionsverein. Roberto Mancili, Gianluca Vialli, Anfang der 90er Meister, Europa Cup-Finale gegen Barcelona und so weiter. Und jetzt ganz, ganz fatal in die Saison gestartet, einen unglaublich desaströsen Transfermarkt erlebt und nach einem 0 zu 3 gegen Berlusconi's Monster, den Aufsteiger, jetzt den Trainer Marco Giampolo entlassen. Mario und ich haben bei Serie Amore eigentlich schon seit Wochen gefragt, wie konnten Sie mit diesem Mann überhaupt in die Saison gehen? Also das ist auch so ein Trainer, bei dem man sich fragt, wie er überhaupt in der Serie A noch an Jobs kommt. Er hat vor vier, fünf Jahren mal eine halbwegs gute Saison damals auch schon bei Sampdoria gehabt und ist seitdem überall, wo er war, krachend gescheitert. Also jetzt auch seinen Punkteschnitt seit in diesem Jahr, glaube ich, bei 0,8 oder so. Und dazu eben die Mannschaft, die er hingestellt bekommen hat. Das spricht ja auch Bände, wenn auch wieder ein aus der Bundesliga bekanntes Gesicht, wenn Abdelhamid Sabiri, ein paar der Born-Fans wissen Bescheid, dein bester Spieler ist, dann muss wirklich gewaltig was schief gelaufen sein. Also klar gibt es im Sturm Namen wie Quagliarella oder Caputo irgendwie noch so sehr coole Typen, aber die sind auch 35 und 39. Könnte man jetzt sagen Serie A-Klischee, aber näher bringen auch mittlerweile nicht mehr die Leistung so wirklich. Und ja, es spricht im Moment, auch wenn es wiederum so gesagt nur früh in der Saison ist, im Moment spricht alles dafür, dass der Abstiegskampf bis wirklich ganz bis zum Schluss da ist. Und das ist wirklich enorm schade, denn der Verein ist wirklich einer der größten Traditionsvereine in Italien. Hat auch einfach immer die schönsten Heimtrikots, also riecht das auf jeden Fall mal an. Ja, und das tut mir echt immer so ein bisschen im Herzen, wie die seit die Saison oder eigentlich auch schon das gesamte Kalenderjahr auftreten. Spielerisch ist das auch einfach total uninspiriert. Ja, im Grunde genommen gar nichts, also die Spiele kann man sich fast nicht angucken. Ja, jetzt muss man natürlich mal sehen, wer von Jean-Paulo übernimmt. Heißester Kandidat, vielleicht ist es dann auch schon bei Upload der Folge fix, ist Dejan Stankovic, der ja bei Roter Stern Belgrad, meine ich, relativ gute Arbeit geleistet hat. Da stelle ich mir allerdings die Frage, wie er beraten sein muss, dass er sich diesen Verein in dieser Situation als erste Station in Italien, wo er lange bei Inter und bei Lazio gespielt hat, wie er sich diesen Verein in dieser Situation antun kann.
Kannst du mir erklären, hat das auch wirtschaftliche Gründe, dass jetzt die Transferperiode wirklich enttäuschend verlaufen ist, aus Sicht von Sampdoria? Man hat Spieler wie Damsgaard abgegeben, Morten Torsby, das haben bestimmt auch die Hörer vielleicht mitbekommen, der ist zur Union gewechselt und spielt da jetzt ja sehr gut. Und man hat einen deutlichen Transferüberschuss erzielt, was ja grundsätzlich jetzt erstmal nichts Schlechtes ist. Aber du hast es ja schon angesprochen, Sabiri, der für eine korrekturierte Ablöse von einer Million gekommen ist, arg viel mehr hat man nicht ausgegeben. Caputo war mit dreieinhalb Millionen der teuerste Spieler. War das wirtschaftlicher Zwang, dass man so viel mehr für Spieler eingenommen hat, als man ausgeben konnte? Oder Fehleinschätzung?
Tatsächlich hat das was mit wirtschaftlichem Zwang zu tun. Bei Sampdoria gab es auch wieder bei diesem Besitzerthema vor nicht ganz einem Jahr, vor zehn Monaten, einen Besitzerwechsel. Massimo Ferrero, der langjährige Patron des Vereins, musste den Verein verkaufen. Marco Lanna, über den ich persönlich gar nicht so viel weiß, ist seitdem der Präsident und Besitzer. Ferrero hatte auch mit der Justiz auf jeden Fall zu tun. Kann sogar sein, dass er aktuell im Gefängnis sitzt oder auf jeden Fall ein Verfahren gegen ihn läuft. Der hat vorher immer die Hand auf jeden Fall drauf gehabt bei den Ausgaben und hat eigentlich auch immer so nach oben geschielt. Hat sich dann aber so typisch italienischer Club-Chef ein bisschen eigenverliebt und ein bisschen redselig selbst ins Abseits quasi katapultiert. Also mit wirren Trainerwechseln und eben auch dem Verkauf von Stammspielern, um vielleicht seine eigenen finanziellen Probleme ein bisschen zu übertönchen im Zuge der Corona-Pandemie. Es hat so einen Abwärtsstrudel genommen. Ich glaube, der neue Besitzer oder die neuen Besitzer sind bisher nicht bereit, so wirklich viel in den Verein zu investieren oder sie können es nicht. Da muss ich mich tatsächlich auch nochmal genauer einlesen.
Ja, interessant. Da haben wir sie mal wieder. Die Investoren im Fußball. Wird nicht alles besser, wenn man sie reinholt. Aber gut, ich habe auch das Gefühl, das habe ich jetzt schon sehr, sehr häufig gemacht, diesen Punkt hier. Aber es macht halt auch so Spaß, nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, weil die deutsche Diskussion zu 50 plus 1 bemerkenswert oberflächlich geführt wird. Aber jetzt wollen wir noch ein letztes Mal auf La Liga gucken, Nils. Da haben wir, also ein Thema ist jetzt, glaube ich, schon ein bisschen rumgegangen, also dass Burgos in der 2. Liga jetzt nicht so wirklich viele Tore erzielt hat in den letzten Spielen oder auch nicht viele kassiert hat. Also man kann es positiv und negativ sehen. Das ist mir jetzt schon auf diversen Seiten über den Weg gelaufen. Wenn nicht, dann guckt euch das nochmal an, ist wirklich beeindruckend. Es gibt aber noch etwas, was mich jetzt mehr catcht, denn wir wissen ja, im Podcastbereich funktioniert True Crime sehr gut. Und wenn du mir einen blutigen Wechsel ankündigst als Thema, dann muss ich dazu packen. Worum geht es?
Ja, es geht um Raul de Tomas. Der ist jetzt vor zwei, drei Wochen, also nach dem Transferfensterende, doch noch gewechselt von Espanol zurück zu Rayo Vallecano, wo er schon auch mal eine erfolgreiche Zeit hatte. Ja, und da kam es zu blutigen Verhandlungen. In dem Fall hat es Martin Presa getroffen. Das ist der Präsident von Rayo. Ein sehr umstrittener Präsident, auch zwilligte Person, mit irgendwie Verbindungen zu rechtsextremen Parteien. Egal, der hat eine gebrochene Nase bekommen nach einer Kopfnuss. Und wie er selbst sagt, kam die wohl vom Berater von Raúl de Tomás. Der heißt Ivan García. Gab dann Anzeige, Krankenhausaufenthalt natürlich. Das während der Verhandlungen einfach mal eine Kopfnuss auspacken, jemanden die Nase brechen. Das ist schon mal kurios, aber ich finde dann noch kurioser, ist dann, dass der Transfer dann zwei, drei Tage später trotzdem noch über die Bühne gegangen ist. Also der darf natürlich jetzt nicht spielen, weil Transfer während der Registrierperiode öffnet erst wieder im Januar. Er ist jetzt ein halbes Jahr WM-Zug natürlich dadurch auch abgefahren, aber das ist so eine Geschichte, das ist hängen geblieben, ist auf jeden Fall erzählenswert und zeigt, wie, naja, was für ein komisches Umfeld manche Spieler, aber auch manche Präsidenten vielleicht haben. Naja, er wird es überleben.
Ja, aber weiß man denn da mehr, warum es zu dieser Kopfnuss gekommen ist? Also das ist ja völlig bizarr.
Na ja, einfach in den Verhandlungen, unterschiedliche Vorstellungen, dann irgendwie, wenn man nicht ganz so Gentleman-like, nicht ganz so professionell auftritt, und das von beiden Seiten, jetzt meine ich das, dann kann das nicht passieren. Aber dann passiert bei zwielichtem Personen das vielleicht mal. Presa hatte dann nur mal gegenüber Radiosender Kope gesagt. Von wegen, die Kopfnuss kam absolut unerwartet. Sowas macht einen krimineller. Er ist sehr feige. Und jetzt sage ich Spanisch, i muy de mierda. Also das kann man dann übersetzen, wie man will. Ja, einfach weil die Typen da wohl nicht ganz sauber sind. Wie gesagt, Presa extrem umstritten bei Radio auch. Da ist öfter mal, wenn so ein rechtsextremer Politiker auf der Tribüne ist, kommen danach die Fans in ABC-Schutzanzügen und reinigen das Stadion. Da gab es schon beeindruckende Bilder. Und es passt dann doch irgendwie. Wenn sowas passiert, dann wohl bei Radio und bei Roland Thomas Berater.
Ja, also das war ein buntes Thema zum Raussteißen. Beziehungsweise auch ein bisschen braunes Thema. Aber das gehört dann anscheinend leider auch mit dazu. Ich danke euch dreien sehr herzlich. Ich danke zum einen Nils Kern von realtotal.de und vom Tikitaka-Podcast. Danke dir, lieber Nils.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, ich freue mich auch schon sehr. Danke an Alexis Menuge, der bald seinen Podcast zur Ligue 1 launchen wird. Ich freue mich sehr darauf. Bin gespannt auf das Wortspiel, das du dir dafür einfallen lässt. Danke dir, Alexis.
Merci beaucoup und ich freue mich schon aufs nächste Mal.
Dito und danke an Marius Soyke von Serie Amore. Und ihr alle seid natürlich auch, also fast alle, seid bei Twitter zu finden, wird alles in den Show notes verlinkt. Danke dir, Marius, dass du mit dabei warst. Aber wirklich. Und wir hören jetzt gleich hier an dieser Stelle noch Jogi Hebel zur Premier League. Damit wünsche ich euch viel Spaß. Jetzt spreche ich mit Jogi Hebel über die Premier League. Hallo Jogi, schön, dass du hier bist.
Hallo, grüß dich.
Du viel beschäftigter Mensch. Wir haben keinen anderen Aufnahmetermin gefunden. Aber so ist das halt. Du reitest die Welle des Erfolges und hast deswegen auch viel zu tun.
Ja, absolut. Kurz vorm Abstieg, aber ich versuche trotzdem irgendwie durchzukommen.
Ja, du versuchst irgendwie durchzukommen, so wie wir jetzt dann auch durch dieses Premier League-Segment durchkommen werden. Du hast uns auch drei Themen mitgebracht. Und unter anderem ist da der Tabellenführer mit dabei. Und das ist nicht Manchester City. Was ist da los?
Und natürlich auch, man muss mal auch klar sagen, Nord London hat wieder eine Farbe und die ist zumindest mal für ein halbes Jahr rot. Arsenal im Nord-London-Dorby im 192. Habe ich mir gemerkt. Haben sie, muss man echt sagen, gut gestartet. Dann am Ende 3-1 gewonnen. Ja, war natürlich eine rote Karte dabei, die für sehr viele Diskussionen gesagt hat. Überall, weiß nicht, ob du es gesehen hast, Amazon Royale, der so, man nennt das ja, ich habe mir das sagen lassen, von Sebastian Kneisel, der einen Schiedsrichter gefragt hat, man nennt das Stempeln, also wenn das von oben quasi drauf tritt. So heftig fand ich es jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Weil, ja, also in der Reel dachte ich, jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob er ihm Geld gibt, weil eigentlich hat er viel laufen lassen. Das war so mein erster Gedanke. Und dann geht es in die Zeitlupe, und ich versuche die Zeitlupe zu realisieren. Und dann kommen wir zurück, und er steckt die rote Karte wieder rein. Da dachte ich mir, hä, das gibt es jetzt nicht. Hat er einfach nur die rote rausgezogen, um die gelbe zu suchen, oder? Und dann haben wir gesehen, okay, es war noch ein bisschen heftiger. Das hat natürlich dann das Spiel entschieden, und dann war Asen natürlich am Drücker, und hat das dann auch souverän zu Ende gespielt. Aber ich glaube, sie hätten es auch gewonnen, wenn diese rote Karte nicht passiert wäre. Sie waren an dem Tag einfach besser, muss man klar sagen. Und wenn du sieben der ersten acht Spiele gewinnst, Respekt. Also klar, das ist natürlich erst mal nach dem neunten Spieltag, ist ja ein Spieltag ausgefallen, wie wir alle wissen. Aber trotzdem ist es natürlich beeindruckend, muss man ganz klar und deutlich sagen.
Was hat sich denn da verändert bei Arsenal? Oder sind gewisse Puzzleteile jetzt endlich mal zusammengefallen?
Also was man wirklich sieht, ist, dass die Mannschaft eine Mannschaft ist. Das sieht man sofort. Die jubeln zusammen, da pusht der eine den anderen. Gabriel, der Innenverteidiger, der mit einer Faust nochmal in die Fans so rein. Nach 60 Minuten so quasi, hey, gib noch mal alles. Dann Zinchenko wird ausgewechselt, der geht aber nicht raus. Sondern er schaut noch mal in die Mannschaft rein, so aufs Feld. Und sagt noch mal, hey, reißt euch zusammen. Das selbe macht Gabriel und Jesus. Gerade die beiden natürlich, mit City sind es gewinnen gewohnt gewesen, sollen, was man so hört, die Mentalität in der Mannschaft komplett verändert haben. Weil die einfach sagen, hey, wir hören jetzt nicht auf. Und das ist jetzt nicht nur alles lustig, sondern wir arbeiten auch. Und das ist natürlich der große Punkt. Trotzdem, wir haben ganz gute Quellen, was Arsenal betrifft. Der Verein war vor diesem Spiel schon sehr angespannt. Weil sie haben natürlich die ersten Spiele richtig gut gemacht und haben richtig gut gespielt und alles okay und sind da ganz oben. Aber die eine Niederlage war gegen Manchester United, die zu dem Zeitpunkt alles andere als gefestigt waren. Und Arsenal hieß ja eigentlich über allem schwebt. Und trotzdem haben sie dieses Spiel nicht gewonnen, sondern sie haben es verloren. Und dann war natürlich schon so die Frage, jetzt kommt wieder so ein großer, was ist denn, wenn wir dieses Spiel auch wieder verlieren? Denn dann ist dieser Status von, das ist gerade die heißeste Mannschaft der Liga und die können vielleicht sogar Champions League spielen, ziemlich schnell weg. Und davor hatten die schon Respekt und auch ein bisschen Angst im Verein. Die haben ein paar Sachen gemacht, wo man schon gemerkt hat, okay, die sind ein bisschen angespannt. Und dann ist halt genau der Punkt, der dann im Endeffekt wirklich für mich der Entscheidende war. Schaffen die es trotz dieser Anspannung, trotz diesem Druck noch, London Derby, alle werden darüber reden, alle werden über den Verlierer reden, halbes Jahr lang. Dass sie es trotzdem gestanden haben, muss man sagen, ist beeindruckend.
Und was haben sie da gemacht, was eben ein Anzeichen dafür ist, dass sie so ein bisschen unter Druck standen?
Da muss ich jetzt aufpassen, weil das nicht wirklich ein Interner ist. Und dann könntest du rausfinden, wer es ist und wer mir das gesagt haben könnte.
Aber es geht quasi um interne Abläufe. Hat man beim Training was anders gemacht?
War man in der Kommunikation nach außen anders? Es dürften ein paar Leute ein paar Sachen nicht machen, die ihnen eigentlich zugesagt waren. Mediale Auftritte, das habe ich ganz verklausuliert. Aber es wurde eher zurückgehalten in der Kommunikation nach außen. Hey, wir gehen jetzt nicht nach außen vor so einem Spiel. Wir bleiben jetzt eher in uns. Wir brauchen jetzt keine Publicity, sondern wir brauchen jetzt Arbeit.
Wenn ich mir die bisherigen Gegner von Arsenal angucke, dann sehe ich da Crystal Palace, Leicester City, Bournemouth, Fulham, Villa, dann eben die Niederlage gegen United, Brentford und jetzt dieses Spiel gegen Tottenham. Da kann man schon sagen, mit United in Klammern und vor allem Tottenham erst ein richtiges Top-Team mit dabei. Jetzt kommen allerdings die großen Brocken. Heimspiel gegen Liverpool, Heimspiel gegen City. Das wird alles jetzt noch im Oktober stattfinden. Du musst dich jetzt quasi festlegen, bevor wir diese Spiele gesehen haben. Danach werden wir natürlich schlauer sein. Aber hat es denn, Arsene, deiner Meinung nach, im Petto, dass man da mithalten kann?
Das würde ich schon sagen. Die Frage ist natürlich, ist ja auch ein Thema. Liverpool, so wie die momentan spielen, hat man es absolut im Petto. Weil, was glaube ich, haben sie auf jeden Fall. Auf der Höhe sind sie momentan mindestens. Sogar drüber. Citys mit Sicherheit dann. Absolut Benchmark. Das ist klar, weil, so wie die jetzt rollen, werden wir auch gleich noch draufkommen, mit wem die auch rollen, das musst du alles erstmal verteidigen. Und das glaube ich, ist auf jeden Fall die Benchmark, an der sich alles orientieren wird. Aber man muss eine Sache sagen, wenn wir uns natürlich hinstellen und sagen, das ist ja Wahnsinn. Die sind jetzt so und so, nach so und so vielen Spieltagen auf Rang 1, müssen die Meister werden. Ich glaube, das ist übertrieben. Aber zu sagen Champions League, klingt natürlich dann erstmal so quasi, naja, Champions League, ok. Aber für das, wo Arsenal herkommt, wo die eigentlich die letzten Jahre über waren, wäre das wirklich bahnbrechend einfach sagen zu können, sie haben ohne Probleme sich für die Champions League qualifiziert. Und das wäre ein Erfolg, wenn natürlich dann die Meisterschaft am Ende rausspringen würde, weil die anderen beiden oder drei oder vier nicht wollen, dann ist da mit Sicherheit keiner beleidigt. Und vielleicht gibt es so ein Momentum in dieser Mannschaft, dass die sich entwickelt und einfach so sich zusammenfindet und auf dieser Welle reitet, dass sie es doch irgendwie schaffen. Aber also, wenn es Champions League am Ende wird, glaube ich, ist keiner beleidigt.
Ja, das glaube ich. Also das, was ich so wahrgenommen habe bei Arsenal-Fans, die ich kenne, ist eher so ein Augenreiben. Und jetzt vor allem eben nach diesem Wochenende, dass man jetzt auch gegen die Spurs gewonnen hat in diesem so wichtigen Spiel. Aber wenn wir gerade bei Wellen sind, die geritten werden, dann müssen wir dann doch jetzt noch mal über Manchester City und Erling Haaland sprechen. Obwohl er schon im letzten Ligatur-Kurzpass-Kurz-Thema war. Damals hatte er zehn Tore in sechs Spielen, jetzt sind es glaube ich 14 in acht. Es gab ein unglaubliches Manchester-Derby am Wochenende.
Ja, also der Spieler ist wirklich unglaublich. Wir haben ja schon ein paar Vergleiche gezogen, wie Adriano bei Pro Evolution Stock Cup in Real Life. Gab es ja schon irgendwie den Vergleich. Ich habe ja gestern im Podcast bei uns gesagt, dass es eigentlich so wirkt, als würde immer, wenn der Ball zu ihm kommen, der Schwierigkeitsgrad des Spiels nach unten gestellt werden. Und alle anderen sind einen Schritt langsamer. Es ist einfach mega beeindruckend, was er spielt. Trotzdem, ich habe eine ganz nette Zahl zugeschickt bekommen. Man muss sich mal überlegen, der hat einen Expected Goals Wert. Das finde ich richtig spannend. 14 Tore. Und raten mal, was ein Expected Goals Wert ist.
Na ja, wenn du es jetzt so sagst, wird er wahrscheinlich sogar höher sein. Wahrscheinlich 15.
Nee, der ist bei 8,6 oder so.
Ach so, ach krass.
Das ist komplett verrückt. Aber, und jetzt ist natürlich der Punkt, das haben wir gestern mit Uli auch darüber diskutiert. Die Frage ist natürlich, warum ist das so? Der kriegt halt einfach auch wirklich Bälle serviert von anderen Spielern dieses Jahr. Also ich glaube nicht, dass der in Dortmund das Katastrophal schlechter gewesen wäre. Aber der kriegt natürlich, der hat natürlich eine Bräune, der einen Dinger auflegt, der hat einen Foden, der einen Dinger auflegt. Dann hat City natürlich dieses Konstrukt, das natürlich so erdrückend ist für einen Gegner, dass die einen allein schon mal 70% Ballbesitz haben. Und dann passt das natürlich perfekt. Er lauert immer um diese Drafraum-Ecke, um diese Viererkette-Ecke rum oder Dreierkette, was auch immer, und läuft dann im richtigen Moment ein. Und dann kriegt er halt den Ball auch zugespielt von diesen Spielern. Die Räume sind da, und dann macht er die halt. Der ist natürlich wirklich beeindruckend, aber Citys Spiel ist natürlich auch perfekt auf ihn zugeschnitten. Und das passt halt einfach nur. Das ist nicht so, dass die sagen, wir achten jetzt auf den so sehr, sondern er macht einfach genau das, was die Mittelfeldspieler brauchen. Und die Mittelfeldspieler machen genau das, was er braucht. Das passt einfach perfekt. Und dann kann der halt so was machen. Ist auch krass, die Zahl hat Uli rausgesucht. Er stand zweimal im Upside bis jetzt. Und der Typ macht eigentlich nichts anderes, als Tiefe anzugreifen. Das ist einfach ein beeindruckender Fußballer, muss man klar sagen. Trotzdem, die eine Szene, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das das dritte Tor ist. Der Bräune kann einfach vier Manchester-Spieler stehen lassen, als wäre es nichts. Und spielt dann den Ball in die Tiefe und er haut ihn rein. Manchester United war an dem Tag auch gerade in der ersten Hälfte wirklich einfach nicht auf dem Level.
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch so ein bisschen meine Frage gewesen, ob das vielleicht so der unbeachtete Nebenaspekt dieser Haarland-Manie ist, dass dadurch, dass sich alles so auf ihn konzentriert, vielleicht auch der Raum für andere offen wird. Ich meine, es gab ja noch jemand anderen, der einen Dreierpack gemacht hat mit vier Frauen in diesem Manchester-Derby. Das ist ja vielleicht auch ein ganz guter Hinweis darauf. Kann es eben sein, dass er es auch seinen Mitspielern leichter macht, weil er eben nicht nur dieser Zielspieler ist, sondern sich auch mindestens ein Verteidiger eher zwei wirklich auf ihn konzentrieren müssen? Und die werden ja dann auch gepinnt, also taktisch gesehen jetzt. Wenn er immer an der Abseitskante steht, dann sind es schon mal zwei Spieler, einer definitiv eher, wahrscheinlich sogar zwei, die sich nicht trauen, rauszurücken, wenn jemand anderes, wie zum Beispiel ein De Bruyne, wie zum Beispiel ein Grealish, wie zum Beispiel ein Silver, antribbelt und über den Zwischenraum reinkommt.
Ja genau, und das ist ja ein sehr interessanter Punkt. Wenn du dir mal den Masterplan City-Angriff vorstellst, dann ist es ja meistens irgendwie, dass sie versuchen, in diese, man nennt das glaube ich, Strafraumtaschen zu kommen. Also da so ungefähr ans tiefe Fünfer-Eck, so ungefähr. Und da dann quasi, also sich irgendwie durchzukombinieren, mit einem Doppelpass vielleicht dahin zu kommen. Und dann ja eigentlich zurück auf den Elfer, zwischen Elfer und der Fünfer-Linie, dort den Ball reinzuspielen, damit der Stürmer nur noch reinschieben kann. So hat die Aguero quasi 90% an die Tore geschossen bei City. Weil es ja eigentlich immer dieselbe war, versuchen im Dreieck da rauszuspielen, dann ist man an der Grundlinie, legt den Ball nochmal zurück und der schiebt ihn nur noch rein. Das war ja eigentlich immer das. Und wenn man dann aber überlegt, dass ja eigentlich die letzten Jahre über kein Mittelstürmer da war, und sie schwierig hatten, sich dort reinzukombinieren, oder selbst wenn sie es getan haben, dann war halt keiner da, der irgendwie ablegen konnte. Jetzt ist es so, es konzentriert sich, wie du sagst, mehrere Leute auf Haarland. Du kannst dich leichter da rein kombinieren. In dem Moment, wo du da bist, denkt sich die ganze Abwehr, oh mein Gott, wir müssen da jetzt wieder hin. Wir müssen da wieder zumachen. Und in dem Moment ist der Haarland wieder frei. Also das hat alles so Domino-Effekte in diesem ganzen Spiel. Dass halt immer irgendwo einer frei ist, weil sich halt immer mehrere Leute auf Haarland konzentrieren müssen. Ein paar müssen sich dann auf die Bäume konzentrieren. Dann ist der Foden plötzlich völlig frei. Dann denkst du dir, warte mal kurz, jetzt müssen wir den Foden mal zustellen. Er hat schon zwei Tore, dann ist der Haarland wieder frei. Die haben einfach so eine unfassbare Qualität davor, dass man einfach wirklich sagen muss, das ist einfach beeindruckend und fast schon Tütenmode irgendwie.
Aber würdest du sagen, dass sich da jetzt noch mal irgendwas verändert hat, jenseits der Person Erling Haarland? Das ist halt jetzt auch eine gute Geschichte. Deswegen erzählen wir die alle so gerne. Wenn man da jetzt noch mal im Detail drauf gucken würde, dann könnte ich schon ehrlich gesagt eine ähnliche Argumentation fahren, wie mit Arsenal, dass man sagen könnte, naja, Manchester war jetzt vielleicht auch der erste, in Anführungszeichen, richtige Gegner auf Augenhöhe. Ich will es nicht kleinreden, aber wir sind ja auch, wir fallen ja auch immer gerne auf so Narrative rein, weil sie auch so schön sind. Hat sich denn auch was verändert bei Manchester City? Spielen die jetzt auf einem anderen Niveau? Oder ist es halt das sehr hohe Niveau der Vorsaison ergänzt um jemanden, der halt extrem gut im Torabschluss ist?
Muss man auch sagen. Mein 3-3 gegen Newcastle, da hat er einmal getroffen. Dieses 4-0 gegen Bournemouth, das habe ich zum Beispiel kommentiert, da war er ja mehr oder minder abgemeldet. Da hat er kaum wirklich stattgefunden. Also natürlich, wenn die mal rollen und er einfach abschließen kann, dann ist das mit, ja, man kann nicht reden, was der für eine Qualität hat. Aber ich will das dann schon mal sehen, wie es dann in diesen großen Spielen ist, aber dann die Chancen eben auch bekommt. Wenn es dann vielleicht mal enger wird, wenn vielleicht mal cleverer gegen ihn verteidigt wird und vielleicht auch das Tempo beim Gegner ein bisschen höher ist. Da bin ich schon gespannt, wie es dann aussieht. Weil wir haben es ja, also zum Beispiel, man muss ja schon sagen, sie haben Sterling verloren. Ich finde, dass das schon ein Spieler ist, der wichtig ist. Das ist schon ein guter Spieler. Sie haben Sincenco verloren, sie haben Gabriel Jesus verloren. Der Kader ist, finde ich, jetzt nicht mehr ganz so breit. Calvin Phillips, der Neuzugang, ist quasi immer verletzt. Also der Kader ist nicht mehr ganz so breit. Sie haben keinen wirklichen Linksverteidiger in dieser Saison. Sie haben schon auch ein paar Fragezeichen. Das interessiert natürlich jetzt keinen Menschen. Wenn die so spielen und so hoch gewinnen, dann gibt es niemanden, der Fragen stellt. Da bist du wahrscheinlich der Einzige. Aber es wird so weit kommen, dass auch über City diskutiert wird, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Wahrscheinlich würde er mir genau das Gegenteil beweisen, aber 14 Tore in 8 Spielen, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er auf diesem Niveau weitermachen kann, weil irgendwann wird es auch jemanden geben, der ihn stoppt. Und dann bin ich gespannt, was City als Alternativen hat. Wenn er dann eben raus ist, wenn sich dann vielleicht schon viel auf ihn eingespielt hat, dass sie eigentlich immer ihn suchen, er vielleicht aber nicht mehr gefunden werden kann, erzählt dir dann Plan B, ist natürlich viel what-if, aber kann natürlich theoretisch schon sein. Das weißt du besser als ich sogar, wie oft er verletzt war. Lass ihn mal irgendwas haben und der ist ein halbes Jahr raus, was machen sie dann? Dann ist ihm auch ein Sterling weg zum Beispiel, dann hast du natürlich schon wieder ein weniger und kriegst du es dann noch hin, so viel Torgefahr auszustrahlen mit Bernardo Silva, mit Jack Grealish? Das ist dann die Frage.
Ja, wir werden es beobachten. Noch ist City ungeschlagen in der Liga und auf Rang 2 mit 20 Punkten nach 8 Spielen und wir haben einen Trainerwechsel, also einen weiteren Trainerwechsel in der Premier League gesehen. Das ist noch unser kurzes, letztes Thema. Was ist in Wolverhampton los?
Bruno Lars ist entlastet worden nach dem 9. Spieltag. Das haben schon viele vermutet. Es war nicht katastrophal, wie sie gespielt haben. Es war auch nicht katastrophal, was die Ergebnisse betrifft. Aber ich muss einfach so, was wir gehört haben, atmosphärische Störungen gegeben haben. Er ist der Nachfolger von Nuno de Santo. Er sollte ein wenig offensiver spielen, ein wenig attraktiver spielen. Das ist nicht wirklich gelungen, muss man klar sagen. Sie haben gerade mal 3 Tore nach diesen 8 gespielten Spielen, die sie gemacht haben. Das ist einfach viel zu wenig. Sie haben sehr schwache Expected Goals-Werte. Sie spielen sich sehr wenig raus. Sie erzielen auch sehr wenig Tore. Defensiv ist es okay. Neun Gegentore ist so la la. Aber sie sind offensiv so harmlos. Das hat mit Attraktivität auch gar nichts zu tun. Dann, was man hört, muss er mit den Spielern individuell gar nicht gesprochen haben. Wenn, dann war er sehr emotional und sehr aufbrausend. Und teilweise kolärisch, fußballerisch. Ich glaube, taktisch kann man ihm nichts vorwerfen. Das ist mit Sicherheit jemand, der eine Idee hat, der den Kader noch mal umgewälzt hat, der versucht hat, das aufzubessern, was Bruno Espírito Santo verpasst hat. Nämlich, sie wollten eigentlich einen breiteren Kader, einen tieferen Kader. Sie wollten weg von der Dreierkette hin zur Viererkette. Mit schnellen Außenspielern, mit schnelleren Innenverteidiger. Haben dann den Kapitän, Conor Cody, gehen lassen, weil er meinte, der ist A, zu langsam. B, er kann nicht Viererkette spielen. Jetzt spielt aber in Everton genau das. Er spielt Viererkette und es funktioniert. Und bei Wolver Hilton funktioniert es überhaupt nicht. Und was passiert? Er geht am Ende wieder auf die Dreierkette zurück gegen West Ham und spielt dann mit Ruben Neff zum Beispiel hinten drinnen einem zentralen Mittelfeldspieler, einem der besten der Liga. Und sagt zudem, du bist jetzt der zentrale Mann in der Dreierkette. Das sind natürlich so Dinge, die passen hinten und vorne nicht zusammen, muss man ganz klar sagen. Denn er wollte ja die ganze Zeit einen Stürmer haben. Dann hat er ihn am Ende bekommen mit Kaleicic. Der hat sich verletzt. Dann musste er mit Dio Costa nochmal nachbessern. Dann sah es so aus, als wäre der Kader verhältnismäßig breit geworden. Weil man ja z.B. mit Mateusz Nunez, noch ein Spieler verpflichtet, in der Mitte fällt. Dann lässt man Gibson White gehen, dann lässt man Den Donker gehen. Dann ist man am Ende des Tages wieder so weit, dass der Kader eigentlich total dünn ist wieder. Genau da, wo sie eigentlich weg wollten. Das sind alles so Punkte. Irgendwie hat alles nicht mehr zusammengepasst. Ich glaube, er war über die Kaderpolitik auch nicht unbedingt begeistert. Und natürlich dann diese Probleme in der Offensive, dass sie einfach gar keine Gefahr ausgestrahlt haben. Hinten aber auch nicht mehr stabil genug waren. Und dann muss man halt irgendwann mal sagen, okay, wenn es dann auch menschlich nicht mehr passt, dann glaube ich, muss man sich trennen. Schade, weil jetzt glaube ich irgendwie schon, ich fand ihn jetzt nicht unsympathisch, aber die Wolverhampton war mal, wenn du dir überlegst, als die aufgestiegen sind, die haben Geld investiert, die waren so the next big thing, sind zweimal Siebter geworden. Dann dachten alle, jetzt marschieren die in die Champions League. Das stand auch in jeder Saisonvorschau damals. Und was ist passiert? Das war dann nämlich auch zwölfter, vierzehter. Also das ist halt das große Problem. Da hat ein Verein eine riesengroße Chance liegen gelassen. Alle haben sich ein wenig zurückgenommen. Es wurde ein bisschen weniger investiert, ein bisschen weniger progressiv und so weiter. Und jetzt ist man halt wieder da, wo man eigentlich vor dieser Investitionsphase aus China war. Nämlich man ist einfach wieder langweiliges Mittelmarsch, sogar eher etwas drunter. Und jetzt ist es eigentlich wünschenswert, dass es irgendjemand wird, der vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Strahlkraft hat. Amorim wird zum Beispiel schon genannt. Sergio Contessao wird genannt. Aber das wird dich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht überraschen, dass der Pass portugiesisch sein wird.
Ich habe mich schon gefragt, was Trainerkarussell auf portugiesisch heißt.
Genau, ich weiß es auch nicht, aber wir werden es mit Sicherheit rausfinden. Ich kann es daneben bei mal googeln. Aber das ist genau das, was im Endeffekt so momentan kolportiert wird, dass es eben wieder in Portugiese wird. Aber das darf jetzt auch nicht großartig verwundern.
Das überrascht nicht. Also, wo wir hinten aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 18 mit 6 Punkten dahinter, konnte jetzt Leicester zum ersten Mal gewinnen gegen das Schlusslicht Nottingham. Die beiden haben jetzt 4 Punkte. Also inzwischen hat jetzt jedes Team der Premier League einmal gewonnen. Und alle anderen Themen müssen wir dann in der nächsten Ligatur besprechen. Jogi, ich danke dir sehr für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war unsere nächste Rasenfunk Kurzpass Ligatur. Gebt uns gerne Feedback, wie euch die Folge gefallen hat, unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder im sozialen Netzwerk eurer Wahl. Wir sind auf allen Wegen zu erreichen, außer Fax. Ansonsten habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund. Es geht hier weiter im Rasenfunk nach dem nächsten Spieltag der Männer-Bundesliga. Kommt die nächste Folge bis dahin. Bleibt gesund, macht es gut und bleibt uns treu. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk.